MARK MIRCHANDANI: I'm
here with Bob from SeMI.
And today, we're talking
all about knowledge graphs.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Bob, thank you so
much for joining us.
BOB VAN LUIJT:
Thanks for having me.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
First things first.
What is a knowledge graph?
BOB VAN LUIJT: So
a knowledge graph
tries to store real-world
entities in a data object.
And what we tried to do
with knowledge graphs
is to actually try to understand
how the real world works
and derive knowledge rather
than just data from the way
that we stored information.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Right.
Now, that's different from
a traditional database
which just stores information.
BOB VAN LUIJT: Yes.
So, for example, let's say that
you would store information
about a movie.
Then there's all these
relations that you
might have in your head
about the movie, maybe actors
or locations or things
that come to mind.
But if you store that in
a traditional database,
a lot of context just gets lost.
It's just a database--
You could argue that a
database is just dumb.
[INAUDIBLE] It's a dumb
way of storing information.
What you try to do
with a knowledge graph
is to actually keep
that information
and keep that context so that
you get a 360-degree overview
of what you're actually
storing and that people
can query for the knowledge
rather than the raw data
information.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So it sounds
a lot like a traditional graph
database.
But you're also adding in this
knowledge or learning aspect.
BOB VAN LUIJT: Yes,
that's a good point.
So the graph part
is one could argue
that everything
that we store has
a relation to something else.
So, for example,
like, the movies.
If you would look at a movie,
a movie has certain actors.
And they're born
somewhere, and-- well,
et cetera, et cetera.
So that is there's
always a relation.
So that's the graph part.
What the knowledge part
adds on top of that is like,
can we actually try
to derive knowledge
from that information?
So let's say that you would have
an actor who is born in Paris.
But you now query for which
actors come from France.
[INAUDIBLE] actually
says, oh, wait,
now I need to show
this actor who
was born in Paris
because there's
a relation between
Paris and France.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
Weaviate is the product
that you've built as
a knowledge graph.
What makes Weaviate special
among knowledge graphs?
BOB VAN LUIJT: Yeah, so
I would argue that there
are three things there.
So the first thing is is that
we don't store data objects
in a traditional
way, so in a table
or in a traditional graph.
We store it in a space.
And this is a semantic space.
So every time we add
a new data object,
we try to determine what
does that object mean?
What does it represent
in the real world?
And we place it in a space.
So, for example, with
the actor example,
if you would have an actor
who was born in Paris,
then it would be closely
related to France.
So that's how we
store it as one.
The second thing that
we do is that we're
completely API-based.
And that is also where
we stop, if you will.
So we try to enable others to
build these semantic systems.
And thirdly, that is
something that we learned
to the semantic aspect is
that we can now also do
automatic classification,
which basically means that,
to stay with the
example of France,
that if you would have a
country with the name France
and a city with the name
Paris, the knowledge
graph can actually automatically
derive-- hey, wait a second.
That Paris is the
capital of France.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Right, so that
learning aspect comes back in.
How does it actually
do the learning?
I mean, you're inserting the
data by using data objects.
But then it's got to figure
out how these are related.
BOB VAN LUIJT: Yeah, that's
a great question, actually.
So the interesting
thing is like,
how do we define learning?
So we have the data
science aspect of learning.
But we also have the
engineering aspect of learning.
And one of the problems
that we want to solve
is that every time when
you add a new data object,
we didn't want to retrain
the machinery learning model
because it now takes
about 48 hours to train.
So just imagine if you want
to add 1,000 data objects.
Well, that's undoable.
So what we learned was that
the machinery model that we use
has all these vector positions.
So those are representations
of concept in that space.
And what we do is that the
moment that you add data,
we try to algorithmically
determine where
to place it in this space.
So our learning, if you will,
is not necessarily retraining.
It's just trying
to understand where
do we need to place that object
in the space, which makes it
very fast from an engineering
perspective, which
results in a better UX.
So a user doesn't
really notice that they
are working with a
data solution that
incorporates both the machine
learning model and a storage
mechanism.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah, so
how does it actually do?
I mean, you have the data.
You're able to add it in.
It figures out the new things.
But without retraining,
it seems very hard
that it would be able to
learn these new properties.
BOB VAN LUIJT:
Yeah, so there are
three ways how we can do that.
So we have the
out-of-the-box knowledge,
which we like to call
the common knowledge.
So we train it on
open data sets.
So in English,
for example, think
about Wikipedia, the Wiktionary,
but also scientific articles,
et cetera.
So that's what we like to
call the common knowledge.
Now you can do two things.
So there might be
a situation where
you have a very specific domain
knowledge that you want to add.
So think about the use cases
in banking, oil and gas
industry, health
care, et cetera.
So what you can do
to the RESTful API,
you can literally add
a natural language.
So you can say I'm going
to now teach you a concept.
These are the words
of the concept.
And this is the description
in common knowledge,
because if you think how
you and I learn new words,
that's how we do it.
To children, we explain in
common language new concepts.
So what happens
under the hood is
that we take that concept
and a description.
We calculate a new position
in the vector space.
And that's where that
new concept lives.
So if you now start to
add that objects that
talk about that concept,
that's how we give it
its semantic understanding.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
you're able to kind
of teach it, the new concepts.
And then it makes
those new associations
without having to do this new
layer of retraining, basically.
BOB VAN LUIJT:
Exactly, because we
wanted to have this UX
aspect is number one for us.
And then speed plays a role.
So how fast can we do this?
And that's the
beautiful thing, again,
of the factorization
of concepts and words
because we can calculate with
it, which means it's fast.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So what's the
case where a knowledge graph
might not be a good solution?
BOB VAN LUIJT: Yeah,
so, for example,
if you have a lot
of streaming data
or if you have a lot of
logs, for example, that you
need to search too fast--
what we see in practice
is that often you
have a traditional database
and a knowledge graph.
And they live together and then
you solve problems together.
So or, for example,
transactions at a bank.
Then you want to store them
in a transactional fashion.
But if you now want
to search through them
or find specific
things, then that's
where the knowledge graph comes
in and takes that information
and stores it in
a different way.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Right.
So this isn't supposed to
replace databases out there
as a whole.
But it's a new layer of
looking at your data.
BOB VAN LUIJT: Yes, that's,
indeed, what I would argue.
It's just a completely different
way of looking at data.
However, I would
like to say, though,
if people would like to
change our data infrastructure
with Weaviate, I'm all for it.
[LAUGHS]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well,
it's really exciting
to hear about the space.
So thank you very much
for coming in, Bob.
BOB VAN LUIJT: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]